Oh oh my oh my god is it tired another
another video another video I thought I
could cure him by getting rid of his
forehead but it's not enough if I can
beat this game okay here we go
so far we're doing great inflate still
alive still breathing but we got to be
ready for an attack at any point wait
stop stop stop stop stop right right
no you do not go there you go left yes
it turns out no you go left now you are
going left screw that direction moving
left now okay that's a death there why
well I guess I hear oh oh my god you
just died I don't see the [ __ ] point
like it's just you can't just randomly
kill him well I guess I hero awakens in
an open field or whatever under an apple
tree oh my god I am so sorry no you were
supposed to go left I am going laughs I
made a horrible mistake
currently trees killed me sorry won't
happen again go left
okay watch out now you died Congrats
hero what killed me why why say I see
you're playing this game again hmm all
right then well I guess we'll start from
the drill gun our hero awakens and
alright death number whatever moving on
I gotta say
Aynsley don't Shh
[Music]
so the Apple it's the [ __ ] Apple what
about the other one I don't trust
anything now hey look man I haven't seen
this many strokes of death since my last
time masturbating oh my god I'm doing
good I have not your rates yet so far I
have not raged oh I see you're playing
shot and shot right then it turns out
the [ __ ] you dead wrong this [ __ ]
range not me so yes definitely go left
shut up shut up shut up shut the [ __ ] up
shut the [ __ ] up shut I think this
[ __ ] is going to kill me the whole
thing not the whole thing
please no all right I hear oh oh that's
another death well I guess I hero
awakens an open field
[Music]
oh I see you're playing this game again
alright then
I'm father he will awaken no an open
field under an apple tree here actually
goddamnit you have to go left watch out
for that [ __ ] cloud for some reason
this is just getting sad what happened
what happened [ __ ] you man oh no I'm so
sorry please we're great we're doing
great top a top of top class all right
ah Hiro awakens in an open field under a
nap
alright you're not even playing the game
anymore you're just dying now yeah just
keep heading left oh okay alright watch
out it looks like that's a dead end and
then [ __ ] the cloud how do I get past
maybe I love you cloud you maybe it was
just a just shut up just shut up
just yeah better think that while you're
walking right okay now then
[Music]
what do i do oh my god hey how's it
going
Jax but I see here great great video
this has been I hope you're in having I
hope you're having oh oh we're filming
we're filming it like this now this is
this this is how I do all my videos now
okay so now there's the Apple alright
how do I dodge the [ __ ] Apple shut up
oh boy
why okay I need to just I need to just
focus I need to just focus
[Music]
okay I can do this WASD just not gonna
speak and I'm just gonna play
focus
[Music]
okay we're getting somewhere here the
house is a sign that says we did it okay
if you oh my god for [ __ ] sake why why
just one uh hero+ there was actually how
do we get past that like our hero has
passed a sign that actually says I
believe is oh my god I can read this I
can I can do this
[Music]
[Applause]
I can read this no no [ __ ] you Maine
[ __ ] you got him give me a gun give me a
[ __ ] gun I'll kill oh I'll kill him
me yes that's what it says yeah no we're
not going to get the money I don't know
why am I here why am I here I don't
underst I don't understand I don't
understand I'm not good at games this is
not my kind of game all right
whoa okay I just got to be faster it's
got to be faster it's gotta be faster
gotta be faster that was just gotta be
fast okay yeah okay no matter [ __ ]
white and it's just kind of [ __ ]
annoying me at this point okay here we
go wait watch this no not gonna watch
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] just happened I'm
alive I'm alive I'm breathing I'm alive
I'm alive I'm alive Apple
[ __ ] Apple this is how you dog that's
how it's done it's been a long day
without you my friend and I'll tell you
all about it when I see you again we've
come a long way from where we began oh
I'll tell you all about it when I'll see
you again when I see you again I see
[Music]
what's made in wall street journal' Wow
what a clever joke